you're looking at Cape Cod Massachusetts
where many are headed for the 4th of
July holiday communities there are
strengthening their defenses against
possible shark attacks at least 12 great
whites were spotted in Cape Cod Bay just
this week Don Dahler is on the beach in
Wellfleet Massachusetts along part of
the Cape Cod National Seashore Don when
was the capes last deadly shark attack
yeah hey good morning well it hasn't
been quite a year in fact it was last
September that a 26 year old man was
killed by a great white right off the
beach here and that was the first such
attack in 82 years so you can see it's
very rare but still these most recent
sightings may have some tourists and
communities nervous and local officials
searching for solutions response plan
exactly Orleans Fire Chief Anthony
Pike's job is protecting parts of this
40 mile stretch of coastline from a
danger you can't always see sharks do
you think people are afraid or do you
think they just accept that this is now
part of life here I think that we're
undergoing a culture change here and
Pike says it's the new normal over the
past eight years at least three people
have reportedly been bitten by sharks on
the Cape and shark sightings prompted
the Cape Cod National Seashore
to ban water entry a report at 28 times
last year
that means boosting emergency response
more land lines to combat poor cell
service shark warning signs and these
beachside emergency boxes the first
first-aid box of its kind in the coastal
United States tourniquets eye protection
gloves trauma dressings if you access
this box you have a pretty good cache of
what you may need in a major emergency
they are following the food and the food
unfortunately it is very close to shore
and we are very close to shore
Massachusetts marine biologist Greg
skomal whose team tagged three great
whites in the past few days here says
the exploding seal population is the
reason for the increase in shark
sightings I asked people if you're going
to be in an area where these sharks are
hunting and that's particularly along
the outer Cape parts of Cape Cod Bay as
well this is a natural hunting ground
for this
species and take into consideration the
fact that you are a land animal going in
the ocean and be vigilant and that seal
population is protected by law here it
might seem like there are a lot of shark
sightings off Cape Cod and there are but
actually being attacked and killed by
one well you have statistically a better
chance of being killed by a lightning
strike a car accident or even a dog Tony
thank you very much I remember what that
marine biologist had to say you are a
land animal you're just like they look
at you like a seal or something but I
love wooden aid they give to statistics
it's all good except if you're the one
yes they are the one okay you have just
as much chance very well it is you know
are you getting in the water Anthony I
gotta go I'm gonna be in that
neighborhood and I'm